bienvenue sur cette île de Chupacabra
vous allez devoir survivre pendant 38
jours sans rien vous êtes sûr que c'est
là là parce qu'il y a pas de Villa
peut-être
ils devront dépasser la fin il n'y a pas
de déjeuner ni de dîner quoi la fatigue
ça va bien dormi les trahisons
évidemment que je vais les travailler on
va de contrôler ce soir
oh [ __ ] c'est os sauvegarde un seul de
ces 14 aventuriers succédera à Lionel
qui a remporté les 450 euros une somme
folle rien n'empêchera de gagner les 450
euros la guerre elle fait que commencer
je suis ravi de faire partie de cette
aventure humaine tais-toi maintenant
aucun secret pour moi c'est la bonne
humeur qui me fera gagner mon fils
est-ce que tu es là
c'est le seul moyen de perdre du poids
rapidement
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle le multivers